this is insane and i'm seeing you guys
together right now
the first two jurors okay vic
double eviction from a scale one to ten
how surprised are the
that row is sitting next to you right
now
seven like i'm devastated to see it but
i'm not shocked i
knew the house was gunning for him yeah
and you know the game you're a super fan
so you're not surprised there was going
to be a double eviction but
you know it was just a moment and bro
for you i mean
you fought so hard in this this you
didn't have time to prepare
so here you are are you how are you
doing right now has it sunk in
are you emotionally okay yeah i mean you
said it i really just didn't have
time to prepare the double just goes so
quick so even though i didn't win that
veto
i would have liked to have had the week
to kind of work on people in the house
but because you literally have
minutes to do it it's just really not
feasible so
emotions wise you know obviously i'm
grateful for the experience it was a
phenomenal opportunity
i'm proud of the game that i played
obviously not the results i wanted but
i still get a hand in uh in saying who
gets to represent this season so i'm
happy about that
and vic we love watching you we could
tell you're a super fan
everything you knew about this game
every angle that you played i mean
how would you describe your time in the
house was it everything you expected
yes it was definitely everything i
expected so
unscripted so not rigged like you really
go in there
anything can happen and both of you
competitions talk about being so strong
with i mean the fact that
bro you got three povs you know you two
hohs for you
did you expect to win anything going
into this game
it did not i did not think that's gonna
win as many competitions as i
did and i think that kind of threw me
off that throw off my strategy
it made me a big target in the house and
i wasn't ready for
that and honestly for me like i didn't
even want to win competitions i wanted
to go in i wanted to play this
immaculate social game but
the team's twist at the beginning really
threw me for a loop and my team took
back-to-back losses to start the season
i was
i almost had the boat flipped on me in
week two so after that i was just kind
of put in a position where if i wanted
to stay in the game i had to win some
vetoes and so that's what i did
you definitely needed the last beetle
that's for
you didn't sure it i mean you were a
target from the beginning ro why do you
think that was
i don't know i think um you know
obviously what was on the block and we
too there was an attempt to flip the
vote on me and ironically vic is the one
vote that prevented that from happening
so she is the reason why
i made it this far but she's also kind
of the reason that i'm sitting at the
jury house too because she put up austin
and braden last week as the invisible
hoh so
you know i love vic we have a great
relationship i i think that if we had
stuck together with austin braden and
kyle we could have been running the show
in there but
um things played out as they did and you
know i'm not mad about it a few regrets
but
it's uh it's part of the game so what do
you think of vic's game now that you've
kind of settled with everything that's
happened and vic what do you think of
rose game now that you've kind of
settled with it
i love rosho you played an amazing game
i'm so sad to be sitting here beside him
i definitely would have done things
differently i don't even know why i put
upgraded
in austin like at the time there was no
doubt in my mind that that was the move
i needed to make
looking back
yeah i mean we we have we've talked a
lot about that um you know austin and
braden for sure we're
never putting vic on the block so i
think that's the tough part to kind of
just like look back on
what do i think of vic's game though
obviously she's an incredible player i
love her as a person
she won uh competitions in that house
and really just showed that she was a
super fan and she wanted to play this
game
and so you know she should be extremely
proud of the game that she played and
walk out with her head held high
and what do you think of the ghost
peppers alliance now
i'm pissed not cool
not cool not cool
it's frustrating because i know that's
what they try to do right they go around
the house and try to form alliances
with different people and i knew that
the entire
time it was just how can i build up
this army this resistance to kind of
take them out of the game and
for me that army was you know vic austin
as well and i'm here because of it
so vic do you respect that game
no i'm sorry but i don't i love you
still honestly in the big brother house
you can
play a clean game when i was up on that
block she gave me reasons as to why i
was there
and i was able to you know like tell her
that's not true and
like with evidence with my moves yeah i
was able to be like girl this
ain't it and even when i was able to
prove it it still wasn't enough
and that really bothered me
you